what's good it's your girl Armani Caesar
check me out on bootleg Kev podcast it's
lit
bootleg cab show special guest in here
Buffalo's Finest it's Griselda Zone the
first lady yes
yes Armani Caesar how you doing welcome
it's good to see you good to be here of
course uh your new album is officially
out the Liz too yes highly anticipated
yes uh how's it feel now that it's out
in the world and you're getting
reception and like are you are you happy
with everybody's uh you know take on it
yeah I still feel like you know I've
been getting a lot of love winning I
still feel like it's being digested
because that's something that you got to
listen to a few times to really catch
everything right like just the bars
metaphors double entendras but also like
the flow of it like it's really like in
a sequence of like events that were
really happening right so you're like I
feel like you are uh kind of an anomaly
in a crew like Griselda yeah right like
we think of gun we think of
Conway Benny is high level Coke rap it's
you know yeah it's we know what it is
right and then there's Armani Caesar
who's like you know one of the most
pretty girls in hip-hop and obviously
you could wrap your ass off but you're
also very much like a different
um you're bringing something different
to the crew yeah um when did you
initially link up with gun and like how
did you guys eventually get on each
other's radar to where you ended up
working with Griselda officially so I
met gum back in when I was still living
in Buffalo I was like a teenager and
um we met through DJ Shay that's how I
met all the guys through DJ Shay where I
was in a group all together called buff
City and then once I left for school and
then everybody kind of disbanded you
know did they own who I was in buff City
it was me Conway Benny
um
Hyde was in it rick hide was it shout
out to my guy Rick Hyde yes I just
realized that and like it was like uh
food Crews
um who else is Inbox City this is prior
to you going to college so this is like
how old are you like 18 17. like 17 just
turned 17. wow okay yeah so then I just
kind of you know they met me I went in
there for some studio time
um and they had another wrap chicken
here at the time and Benny was like
helping her write a verse or whatever
because she was gonna be like the first
lady of the city at the time gotcha so
that was like they were going over the
verse and they kept playing instrumental
I wrote my own verse and then somebody
heard me rapping it and then Benny you
know came over heard me tap Shay like yo
like she fired instead of third long
story short I ended up in a group just
like that wow so that was kind of like
the first time you had like really
linked up with the guys over there in
general yeah yeah so you go to school
you said North Carolina Central
HBCU yep uh what were you going to
school for so I was a um I was a few
things
but I ended up a marketing major
business administration with a
concentration of marketing but like all
of my prereqs were like you know pretty
much the same and like Staples that you
needed for every class except for the
hip-hop and context class it was a
hip-hop and contacts class was that the
one that ninth Wonder was teaching yeah
I just saw him repost that so you never
know who's in the classroom yay so it
was crazy like because I even gave him
the mixtape that I had back in the day
it was called bath and body work oh wow
that's great
you know he was he was showing love like
you know he was still he was just real
cool it was a bunch of people in the
class but essentially like it really
kind of got me into a journey of like
going and doing my research on the
Roxanne shantae's on NC lights like the
people that weren't like mainstream like
the Kim's and foxies right so you think
like taking that class kind of helped
you like sharpen your hip-hop Head Metal
if you will for sure I mean we would
just be walking in a class and like he
would be playing a sample and then he
had played a song that sampled it like
you know that kind of thing like so that
got me in my sample bag that got me like
digging for Beats and like even
inspiring me to just go back and listen
to old school music so were you like uh
motivated to go check out little brother
at all his group yeah I love little
brother little brother's one of my
favorite rap groups ever yeah they was
fire fonte well they still are fine they
put a good album out a couple years ago
a few years ago before the pandemic
shout out Fontaine big poop yes I gotta
check that out yeah
um so you go to school
you get the mark you got a degree no you
didn't finish no I didn't finish once I
was told like you know I think this was
like my junior year and I was trying to
figure out like what I wanted to do and
I was just really going to school just
to appease my mother and my advisor was
like look like I see how you go like in
our marketing class and you could
literally sell I swear eskimos so like
if you can Market yourself you could
really much pretty much do anything and
I guess he was trying to motivate me but
it motivated me to like leave like say
[ __ ] this I'm going to go
yeah and you got now I see why you have
you're so success you got a damn
Armani's closet yeah
is this an online store or actual place
that people can visit it's an online
store
um I'm working on making it like a brick
and mortar but I want it to be like an
experience that's super tight yeah okay
so you decide to leave school yeah at
that point in time you stay in North
Carolina you go back home what are you
doing
um I just was going back and forth I was
still kind of like working and then I
got a job at a club and it was just like
I was running it up making money from
there and what were you doing at the
club I was dancing you're tripping okay
so
um transfer all the ladies out to get
their money yes get that bread get that
bag my wife used to be a dancer so no
judgment here I mean listen listen I
know more strippers making more money
than drug dealers to this deck and
a lot riskier less risky yeah even
though yo there's something about strip
club politics that because I used to DJ
a lot at strip clubs so I've been in the
locker rooms I've seen [ __ ] beat the
[ __ ] out of each other oh yeah over like
whose bucket got Fuller from someone
making it rain like the strip club
politics are crazy I ended up getting
fired that's how I ended up stopping
because it was like so it was just I
hated my job but it was like the money
was so good that I was like I was trying
to figure out how I could walk away from
it for good because you know you would
stop a little bit here a little bit
right right yeah but I need some money
let me go work for a weekend yeah or
just you know you get a [ __ ] you you
know yeah you just be like okay well I'm
gonna start a business that don't work
out you already know you're going back
to strip club why why'd you get fired
I Spit on a girl you spit on her yeah I
mean at least she didn't assault her I
mean you kind of did but yeah I really
shouldn't beat her up no I couldn't it
was like security
yeah like that was the only way like I
could kind of get to it was it over like
some money yeah of course because that's
the only reason why I'm here like I
don't give a [ __ ] about you [ __ ] I'm
here you know why I'm here yeah what
city was this this is in Charlotte
Charlotte yeah hey CIAA weekends are
probably lit as [ __ ] oh man it was going
crazy I mean we was on like they would
make like the news like for people
spending like hundreds of thousand
dollars a a night on the weekends that's
crazy what was the most amount of money
in your short-lived dancing career that
you made in one night
[Music]
um
like a little over 20k Jesus Christ yeah
I would never quit
but every night it don't be like that
but tell you something I'd have my ass
out until they would tell me I had to
leave but you know now you explains why
I didn't want to leave it was like you
know no I get it it's also like mentally
taxing I don't think people understand
like your job is to
like make like like it's it I can only
admit my wife's explained it to me like
it is mentally taxing to like hit reset
and then try to like you have to kind of
be everybody's
fantasy slash counselor slash person
they trust like even if it's for 20
minutes like and you do that however
long right and it's like [ __ ] it was a
long night you know like yeah and no
black clubs is a little bit different
because like you know you got to deal
with all the street [ __ ] that'd be
coming into the club yeah so the club I
used to DJI in Phoenix it's called
Jaguars legendary strip club
um it's very much the epicenter of
all of the street [ __ ] in Phoenix
everybody comes there at 2 A.M after the
regular Club gets out and everybody
who's got beef with everybody is all in
the same [ __ ] place every single
[ __ ] night it's it's like you could
sometimes you could feel the [ __ ]
tension in there yeah it's like oh [ __ ]
and imagine it's like you ain't got no
choice you gotta get this [ __ ]
back like you praying that [ __ ] don't
be shooting or you know what I'm saying
like yeah for sure it's crazy it's wild
yeah fights happen like you said people
get right yeah I don't care about the
fights it'd be the shooting part for me
yeah yeah I can imagine well okay so
you're dancing at what point in time you
get when you so you got fired did you
eventually say okay I'm done
um yeah because it was like I wasn't
about to work at No rookie then clubs
like at the time I was like building my
following in the main spot not even so
much at the main spot because a lot of
people didn't even know I danced you
know because I'm just still rapping at
this time yeah I started rapping like I
kept rapping as soon as I got down to
North Carolina okay I mean you gave
ninth wonder your mixtape
bath and body work yes
amazing name I was popping big Shih Tzu
is this on me can we look at this album
artwork anywhere on the internet yes
I'll unfortunately
yeah if it's online it's never going
away I know
it's a great name though oh no no for
real I might have to name like a song
there or something wait I gotta Google
it real quick hold on let's see I think
it's streamable right now still is it oh
so it's on uh Benny on here Conway on
here but like I think what year did this
drop
2013 12 something like that oh my
goodness yeah
oh I look at that okay I see you I see
you in the tub
and the thing about that is it was like
uh shout out to Shea he found his house
in the hood I forgot it was one of his
friend's house but it had like a jacuzzi
in it it was like one of them little
like ratchet houses that look like a
trap house but then when you walk in
it's like renovated so yeah he let us
borrow that to do a little photo shoot
that's great well uh damn that's crazy
that was nine years ago so you're like a
veteran definitely you are not new to
this very much truth it is factual hey
what up y'all bootleg Kev gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our newest
sponsor man shout out to the homies at
hardean Las Vegas that's right the
number one dispensary in the whole state
of Nevada let alone in the whole [ __ ]
country so many choices of Premium
cannabis ladies and gentlemen it is like
how can I put this you walk into it you
go to Jardine in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sent you
be like yo bootleg Capt sent me they're
gonna take care of you at hardean when I
say selection I mean selection of the
best premium cannabis in the world the
best dispensary there's a reason why
hard Dean is world famous follow them
right now Harding underscore Las Vegas
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview uh okay
so you're obviously rapping for a while
um
when did you feel like you started to
catch some traction where you could be
like oh I this might work out for me
um it was just always little things that
happened
um back in back in 2015 I got my first
placement on this um album Rico loves
album actually yes
um on a song called bad attitude
featuring me him and Raekwon wow yeah so
that was like my first album placement
then from there I ended up like signing
and getting a deal but it was like
um it was through somebody I don't want
to mention [ __ ] them but yeah but
essentially
um they left they were the VP at a big
record label and ended up leaving and
then my stuff was kind of like in limbo
for a year so I was just sitting like
not doing [ __ ] that happens a lot it's
like the people that sign you they get a
better job or they get fired and then
there's all these new people that come
in and they're like well we didn't sign
her they don't they don't believe in you
the same way the people who signed you
believed in you right right and if you
sign through somebody else like it don't
really make a difference because it
ain't [ __ ] that they can do they don't
really have the ties so so you kind of
went through like uh the full music
uh industry experience yeah like he was
trying to like stop bags he was trying
to stop people from [ __ ] with me like
it was crazy really is this like a
famous person I mean he's well known
he's not like an industry guy
he industry but like behind the scenes
industry but like what was the big label
it was a big one it was it was one of
the the top five ones yeah for the Def
Jam
what
but yeah but [ __ ] him because
it was a deaf jail okay it wasn't
definitely but like you know so it was
Atlantic
no
so it was Columbia you know what
anyway but like I
have red carpet at the BT was because I
had to decipher him right and you know
it just was a good feeling it was just
like damn you tried to stop and look at
me now that's pretty crazy that someone
would go out of their way to try to
stop money from like a somebody who's
just trying to make ends meet I mean it
happens more often than not especially
the females I think so for sure yeah
I've gotten deals stopped because I
didn't want to [ __ ] with Executives I've
gotten deals stopped because obviously
you know a person wasn't doing anything
and they just wanted me to just sit and
wait like it's crazy yeah there's a
double standard with like uh women in
hip-hop where it's like no matter what
you do like people are always going to
assume the not necessarily the worst but
[ __ ] I told you earlier I was like I
forgot he told me that you and Kodak had
a song coming out because you were
supposed to come up here like a month
ago or something and he was like well
we're waiting for this Kodak ready to
get cleared but then I just saw the
video that you posted a Kodak braiding
your hair and I was like damn kodaks
Dayton Armani Caesar Kodak is just a
certified lover boy so I think he just
give off that like flirty energy yeah
shout out to him he's I mean he bought a
Shannon Brown's ex-wife uh Monique purse
the other night yeah Monica but he's
sweet like that though like he's the
type that you don't even have to be with
him like he just did he buy you anything
he did the record I was happy enough
with that [ __ ]
no I wasn't free but you know it's
discounted he just looked out you know
what I'm saying for for a person that's
still underground and stuff like that
like and I slid in his DM I was like yo
like because I was listening to you know
the album and I'm like damn like we need
a couple more features just to wrap this
up and I um I was just like well [ __ ] it
yeah let's just see what happens he hit
me right back and I sent the song I'm
like let me know if you [ __ ] with it
he sent me right back he was just like
I'm about to stretch the beat I'm gonna
send it back to you he sent them in like
three hours oh [ __ ] yup and then the
next maybe like a week or two later
pulled up and did the video yo that
doesn't happen usually never like
especially an artist that big like
usually you're like waiting like two
months or something you're like yo did
he forget [ __ ] that ain't even as big
as that right like Conway
don't do Conway Conway did take way
longer
I love him as well but like even with
all the backlash that Kodak was getting
at the time you know I was kind of like
leery like you know not so much Larry
because I know that I'm me and I know
how I carry myself so oh was this during
the uh like when there was they were
trying to there was somebody
were they trying to like uh paint him
out to be the
I don't know who it was but it was Lotto
yeah I think it was something like that
but I was gonna say like it is it like
are you starting to
you gotta I feel like as a as a woman in
hip-hop you have to have thick skin and
you gotta kind of like understand like
whether it's right or wrong people are
going to look at you a certain way up
until they hear your music I mean I
think
me coming down to North Carolina and not
knowing nobody and having to establish
myself with the DJs with even my studio
sessions like locking that [ __ ] down for
10 hours at a time
but it's like how you carry yourself
like I'm you know I don't move like how
everybody moves so people know not to
play with me even if it's like at first
you think oh [ __ ] like she fired I'm
gonna shoot my shot it's like once you
see that I'm really about business then
you ain't gonna play with me like that
was uh when did you how long ago did you
guys shoot the video uh we shot it made
of America weekend in Philly when was
that that was like that was like in
September September 1st I want to say
yeah yeah I remember that weekend yeah
that's dope so it was all in Philly yeah
that's what's up uh for you do you do
like were you always kind of like um
because you
are very good at skating Over beats that
you would not expect
women who look like you to rap over were
you always in that bag with like the
Derringer type sound or was that
something that like once you officially
came full circle sign with Griselda that
you embraced a little bit more
um because you're living in North
Carolina you're at in the strip club
music's a certain way so I think
um I was doing that beforehand like
again going back to my first
um project that I ever did with buff
City it was like we was rapping over
heartbeat right so you know of course
when I moved down there it was like then
I learned how to like ride that wave so
now it's like I have an equal balance of
both and when I moved over to you know
when I actually signed to Griselda was
like you know I was excited to do it
just because there was already a lane
for me open there versus me trying to
like start off and do that by myself in
North Carolina
so I didn't walk into a pretty rabid fan
base yeah that was crazy the Griselda
fans are they're very dedicated but I
love them now at first they was a little
mean to me when I first signed why were
they mean because I look like this and
they thought that I couldn't rap yeah
they probably wanted you to be like you
know
280 pounds lesbians
they wanted you to look like Queen
Latifah and set it off
right or be like super you know yeah
yeah for sure they're like yo what what
is going on with Griselda they're over
here signing pretty good right they like
is she gonna be the backup dancer oh
they only sign her because she pretty
they gonna be writing her Rhymes so like
the first Liz was me just proofing all
that [ __ ] wrong so that's why I Came Out
Swinging like I mean yeah and you did a
good job with that thank you do you uh
can you share some of the Insight
because I feel like gun is somebody who
um is influenced influencing a lot of
culture in hip-hop whether or not people
wouldn't acknowledge it
um he's very smart he's a master curator
of course he's an incredible rapper as
well but just in terms of just like his
marketing prowess his business prowess
like what are some of the things that
you were able to pick up from him since
recent like since I again coming to
Griselda officially oh
um just watching
um watching the moves that he makes
watching how he knows how to like
cultivate you know artwork and you know
Bridget with the music knowing like his
influence like over the Griselda fans
and how like they're very big on just
the suspense the
um the merch you know like those are all
things that like a lot of new age people
aren't really doing and me as a woman
and as an entrepreneur like that's
always motivation because I I want to
take what he's doing and take it even
further you know what I'm saying and
even do it my way because I'm a woman I
don't see no woman moving like that so I
want to be like the female yeah there
really is no woman that's like taken
advantage I mean obviously if Nikki
drops the sweater people buy it like
she's got fans that are you know
interesting
um but like I feel like there I haven't
seen like a
a female MC really like dive into the
merch [ __ ] like
some male people have like Tech N9 or
Griselda or whatever so it's wide open
for you for sure facts hey guys we gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
good folks over at bluechoo.com that's
right listen you gotta go to Bluetooth
right now sign up for uh Bluetooth with
the promo code bootleg you're gonna get
your first month for free Bluetooth the
same active ingredient as Viagra Anna
Cialis but in a chewable form that's
right you pop the blue Chew Chew that
thing wash it down with your beverage of
choice and then get to work with that
hard [ __ ] [ __ ] of yours your dick is
going to be harder than trigonometry was
in high school ladies and gentlemen it's
gonna be [ __ ] Raw like you know uh
Ryu and Street Fighter he'd be like are
you looking and he does the
[ __ ] this is gonna be your dick
it's gonna be like ryu's [ __ ]
uppercut you know what I'm saying God
bless whoever's on the receiving end of
that consensually of course uh they're
gonna thank you for taking the blue shoe
so go to bluetooth.com use the promo
code bootleg all right I'm talking free
month right to your doorstep in discreet
packaging no awkward doctor's visits all
right it's all online you don't have to
worry about going and sitting in a
waiting room and be like hey Doc uh my
dick I could use a little a pep in my
step and then it's awkward you gotta
look at this old [ __ ] talking about your
dick he might ask you to pull it out who
[ __ ] knows what's going on at
Bluetooth none of that's happening
boochu.com and they also got the new
brand new a mint flavored chewable which
has vardinophil in it which is the same
active ingredient as Levitra and staxin
which is a little more potent a little
more potent if you need the extra on top
of the extra you know what I mean get
the mint chewable yeah your wife will
thank you your girlfriend no thank you
your boyfriend will thank you whatever
the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'll thank you
as long as it's legal all right let's
get back to the interview go to
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg that's
it yeah uh how much like obviously uh
each album is uh a painting I wanna I'm
not gonna [ __ ] his name up Isaac pelejo
right
um was that because we know that that's
something that uh
gun loves his art I mean I've been to
the store I've seen videos of his crew
in Phoenix because this guy's got
paintings [ __ ] everywhere
um was that like a collaborative idea or
did you just kind of let gun handle cure
rate in the art
um I like gun curate the art
um obviously it was kind of like easier
moving on to the list too because it was
kind of like we're going to continue
with the same makes sense but um you
know the art thing is still something
I'm like learning about like what makes
things like what makes people want to
buy that you know because everybody can
do art but it's like are you gonna get
people to actually want it is it going
to be like dope is it going to be
understood by people came a long way
from Bath and Body work yes for sure in
the in the in the tub and I didn't want
to be on my first album
that makes sense you know because I feel
like people was going to look at it and
be like this ain't gonna sound like what
I think it's gonna sound like or what it
does does sound like right uh for you
who would you consider some of your
biggest influences just as an emcee
um Jay-Z
um Nas Wayne Fab Nikki foxy Remy
um Missy Elliott shout out to Missy yes
I love her that's a Fab too not a lot of
not enough people say Fab yeah that's a
legend no for real like
at his world
um
Styles P Jadakiss
um
like I just I love people that's barred
up you know I like people like a Jay-Z
or even Drake that can like transcend
sounds but it still sounds like them
that's true it's a hard thing to do yeah
yeah I think Drake's the best of that so
like Drake could do a Bad Bunny song and
it's like oh this just sounds like
something Drake would have did because
he was like because it's natural to him
like why not you know there's not a lot
of guys who could really pull off as
much [ __ ] as Drake and it not be like
like you would not like like if Jay-Z
jumped on a Bad Bunny song we probably
all would look at him and be like what's
happening here what's going on here
right why does Jay-Z speaking Spanish
right what else does it and it's like
it's Drake yeah I just assumed Drake
knows every language
like if he hopped on like somebody from
like hungary's [ __ ] song like
tomorrow I'll be like yeah I'd be like
yeah Drake knows Hungarian of course he
does he's Drake he's worldly yes and I
gotta say the guys too like Benny and
Conway obviously like I've been studying
them since I was you know young like
even now I listen to their music before
I start writing sometimes like it does
help when you have two of the best
rappers alive in your crew yeah and like
in my opinion I I always say Conway is
like
Conway is
A J I just think Conway is just his like
ability to convey pain on songs is like
Second To None yeah and I think that's
such a special like uh attribute and
like it makes people like I've seen
[ __ ] crying in the crowd when
he's performing the cow and [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying so that's good to
like pick up on and just be around so
um all right so
you have a song with Kodak Black which
means that uh there's a lot of eyes on
what you're doing right now yeah and you
got the video yes which is a great feat
for an independent artist like yourself
um are you feeling any pressure
for like maybe the next go-round to do a
little bit like more commercial [ __ ]
even though I feel like you did do a
little bit more of that on this project
but like in terms of like you know do
you see yourself doing something like
that
um yeah like it just really depends on
how I'm feeling you know again like I
was doing the commercial [ __ ] more so
before I got signed anyway so it was
always a part of the plan like the thing
was with West Side he was always like
you know you like a star player because
if I go and do a song with you know
Taylor Swift they're gonna look at me
like I'm crazy right but you know you do
it and it's gonna make sense because you
know how to do both you know what I'm
saying so you're kind of able to like
even bridge the gap between Griselda
fans and mainstream by doing the things
that you're doing and and being a female
artist that can actually rap that looks
good that you know can sing that you
know writes all her own music so it was
pretty much just like easy so I do plan
on like getting into the more mainstream
stuff it's also like I think being in
the strip club as long as you have like
you also like whether you want to like
you actually kind of like low-key become
an a r in there you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah and like you kind of start to
understand music and like how like what
makes people react to certain [ __ ] in
the club or what music is you know who
look look I always talk about this with
people I think future is the greatest
Club artist of all time
I think it's future
number one and then everybody I mean you
can figure out who the rest is but I
think future
is the greatest Club artist ever it
depends on the type of clubs I go to at
least it depends it's like you gotta I
don't know so many things go into that
it's like the error because you know
Rick Ross and Jeezy had the game in a
Chokehold for as far as the strip clubs
that I used to work at right right
because it was all adult boys that's all
they wanted to hear are Boosie yeah I
mean yeah you were in you were in North
Carolina yeah but like actual like
mainstream stuff yeah absolutely like
future for sure
Drake for sure Drake gonna get the
ladies like Future Drake
um little baby
I don't think he's quite there yet
clubwise really he's up there he's up
there but he's he's up there but uh
Little John Little John for sure that's
why I said errors because little John
had everything in the choke code
greatest Club song ever though
an old one it's Old Back That Ass Up by
juveniles the number one song in club
history yeah for sure no matter what
club you're in it could be the most
ratchet place in the world it could be
[ __ ] the most high-end Club in Ibiza
if they play Back That Ass Up it's okay
oh for sure because it's just you're
gonna immediately run to the Dance Floor
Just You Gotta like turn around get that
one last little song in before you leave
like that's the one that's the one
that's gonna turn them around uh
anything like you obviously you have
your uh Boutique your online boutique
anything else you're working on besides
the online clothes just expanding the
brand like leveling up like everything
that I'm doing as far as like my music
my shows my you know my brand my
Boutique
um just trying to just capitalize on the
platform that I already have so taking
deals whether it'll be a movie you know
merch you know collabs and stuff like
that like I want to get into more beauty
stuff like I'm just taking my brain and
expanding it to the next level hey we
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our partners at Odd Socks
our presenting sponsor here at the
bootlegate podcast listen Christmas time
is approaching faster than you think I
mean we're like [ __ ] a month and a
half away or some [ __ ] whatever uh get
some Odd Socks for your folks go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and you'll save 20 off at
checkout the most comfortable socks in
the world that's right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy literally the most
comfortable sock in the world I'm
holding the [ __ ] sock right now you
can save 20 off plus they got boxers now
baby all right go to odd
socksofficial.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at Odd Socks and the podcast at
the same [ __ ] time let's get back to
the interview any of the uh OG female
rappers reach out and tap in with you
yet
um so like a few years ago
um foxy had reached out
um I feel like I don't that's sounds
very rare because I've never heard her
do that yeah um it was a guy that I knew
um from New York and he knew somebody
that she knew and I think she had seen
like a picture of me or something like
that long story short they got us on the
phone and
um she just shows so much love she was
just super like yo you fire like even
your look remind me of like something I
would do like she was just real cool do
you feel like um I feel like there's
like this weird civil war between like
cardi B and Nicki Minaj and whoever
they're friends with all at the same
time it's very it's very frustrating
it's just someone who likes both of them
where it's just like guys all right yeah
I get it but it's just like Manny it
just feels like it just feels like it's
like the most like weirdly catty
situation on Twitter every other week
where I'm just like why is
who's cardi beefing right now who's
Nikki beefing with now why can't
everyone just get along and I know that
it like yeah I mean it's a female it's
it's not a female rapper thing men men
beef but I'm saying I'm speaking at it
from like somebody who loves female MCS
when you see something like that like
not necessarily specific to either of
them because I'm trying to get you
caught up with no barbs
um but in terms of like uh you know just
kind of the the beef between a lot of
female rappers are you like trying to
avoid that at all costs or you know I'm
just trying to avoid any kind of
negativity I feel like you know it's a
blessing to be able to get paid for
doing what I'm doing right and like you
just gotta pay attention to the things
that matter like that beef [ __ ] who
don't like you who's [ __ ] who who
like that [ __ ] don't matter to me right
I ain't never been in no drama like that
in my personal life so I'm definitely
not gonna do it at work or in publicly
yeah yo I saw uh when the shooting
happened in Buffalo
um I saw you had said that uh when you
were growing up you worked at not that
same location yeah but you worked at a
different one of those girls yeah that
was obviously an extremely um I was a
pretty crazy day yeah
um were you in town when that happened
no but my mom well first my grandmother
had called me I was getting on a plane I
actually was on my way to a show because
this was during like the Griselda tour
right
um and my grandmother called me and was
like Hey can you turn on those because
she don't she like stupid she don't do
no internet she don't do anything
she was like yo
um I heard that it was a shooting or
something at um a grocery store can you
look it up so then I looked it up and I
seen that it was at tops and this tops
is around the corner from where like my
mom lives at wow so like and then I
called my mom to check on her because
she goes there all the time and my mom
was like hysterical and crying and she
was like I was on my way there and this
time the third it was just it was a lot
yeah now that [ __ ] was terrible your mom
was on the way there
Jesus yeah and it's not like again you
you can get anywhere in Buffalo 10 to 15
minutes so just imagine like you live
around the corner you right there and
then you're seeing all these cop cars
and it was crazy it was bodies out there
it was just wow yeah Buffalo is a place
that like I said I went there for a
couple of days and I really I really
liked it like I really thought Buffalo
was like a Vibe and I didn't know what
to expect going there but it was very uh
it wasn't as cold as I'd uh thought it
was going to be as we discussed the food
was solid but it just out like its own
like I've been to Detroit before and
I've heard people compared to Troy and
buffalo but I just felt like its own
thing like what part of Buffalo are you
from I'm from the east side of Buffalo
like I grew up in a fruit belt and you
know I stayed like
uh like in the east side like they call
it Bucktown Cold Springs I stayed in the
area nice uh what's first of all next
For You music wise you're working this
album I'm sure there's more music videos
coming are you already recording new
[ __ ] oh yeah it's already in a clip I'm
dropping top of the Year already and I
go let y'all wait two years for no
nothing no more yeah yeah it was a long
way yeah why the wait
um well it was a lot that happened
obviously like it was mid pandemic so it
was a lot of things that needed to be
worked out with that but I just think
now like I'm just more Hands-On with my
[ __ ] I'm more in charge of my [ __ ] like
even when it came down from everything
from like my
um roll out you know I had my team or
whatever so shout out to them but you
know my mixes to the content that I was
dropping to my feature like so
everything like you know I'm really more
so Hands-On with mine and I think that
that's important for a lot of women to
do just be in charge of your own [ __ ]
for the first album were you not like as
Hands-On well the first album was kind
of shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] galaxies
always [ __ ] see that's why you need
an iPhone I got both oh it's okay guys
how heavy not bad the first one was
really like cut and dry was super easy I
didn't obviously um have as much of a
rollout as I did with this one but I
recorded um that lives in about seven
days not even seven days three days I
told Wes I was gonna give him seven days
because I was scared to come outside
after I got covered and then
um well you recorded the first album in
three days yeah wow yeah we drove to
what we call the five it's in Atlanta
and it's like in the basement in one of
West houses and it's like super grimy
like
um don't watch TV Travis He um did like
most of the graffiti artwork in there
got all the artwork up there they got
like a green light that's like super
muddy and it's just a Vibe so I gave
myself seven days to do it I left in
three because I had my Boutique that had
just started and I needed to get back to
that check you out and
um you know long story short you know
when it was time to like package up
everything you know West kind of like
handled everything with that even with
some of the Beats I was doing I didn't
even know my first single was a Primo
beat until after I had recorded it
because it didn't have no scratches on
it oh you didn't know you didn't know
you were rapping on a Premiere Beach no
he would because it didn't have no
scratch you know right yeah he's got the
hooks yeah he was just like after I
recorded it we listened back to it
he was like okay I'm gonna send this to
Primo so you can put the scratches on
and not turn around I'm like DJ Premiere
yeah which Primo are we talking about
yeah I'm like nah let me do it over
again he was like nah it sounds amazing
like that was one project where it was
like
I didn't do a lot of singing on it or
anything like that it was just pretty
much like
bars and you know as far as like the
concept and everything like that like
Wes did it and it's this time around it
was like okay well I wanted to be more
like female empowerment I wanted to be
more like me like telling my story for
real I wanted to open up on different
songs that's why you got songs like El
Puro with me and Conway going back and
forth once I'm like almost like a
relationship type of song you know I'm
singing a lot more on it I mean I got a
song called First Wives Club on it
that's literally saying like [ __ ] I'm
not your [ __ ] so but the guys love it
wait wait wait
First Wives Club what is the theme of
this song
um so it's like a women's empowerment
song aquatic First Wives Club because
I'm saying like You Don't Own Me and I
heard that song originally on the First
Wives Club movie and gotten yeah and I
got into was it Goldie Hawn in that
movie Cody huh yeah what was the other I
don't remember a bunch of old white
[ __ ] was in that movie but that would
be my favorite short stuff Goldie Hawn
was one of them yes she's so bad but you
ever been married or close to getting
married
yes so you've been married
you've been married in your day I've
been close to being married not actually
married though so you got you were
engaged
yeah something like that I mean did you
have a ring
we was close to giving me it was a very
very close relationship did you have a
ring
yes I'm always gonna have a ring well
they so you were engaged yeah so what
happened he cheated
it just didn't work out damn yeah we
just went into two separate
paths yeah but God bless him he's doing
really well so well that's good that's
positive usually when that kind of thing
happens you're like yo [ __ ] him he ain't
[ __ ] by the way track hates about that
[ __ ] ass [ __ ]
I mean I get to get that out in my music
but that's why I don't never feel no way
like I get over [ __ ] very quick I don't
stay mad alone it's a nice trait to have
yeah yeah because you can't you have a
short memory I gotta I don't got a short
memory with stuff that matters but a lot
of [ __ ] is just like
I'll be over because I'll be having so
much other [ __ ] going on in my life like
that actually matters and requires my
attention and for me to show up and be
happy and [ __ ] that I can't afford to
waste my time being mad or bitter or
anything like that like that ain't gonna
give me no money and it's only going to
make even more bad [ __ ] come your way
what up y'all we gonna stop the
interview real quick tell you about our
good friends at my bookie that's right
man my bookie is where you want to get
this money and uh enjoy uh being a
degenerate like myself and it's the best
time of the year to be a degenerate
because NFL season is uh obviously we
are in the midst of a crazy NFL season
NBA season just started World Series is
going down and you can get your bets in
right now go to my bookie and sign up
for a new account using the promo code
bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g you sign up right now they
will match your first deposit that's
right put in a thousand oh they'll give
you another thousand to gamble with
that's free money free money to gamble
with let's get in on this action man NFL
season I'm loving this part of the year
so much good just everything to bet on
football basketball [ __ ] UFC uh NFL
baseball whatever now is the best time
to get your gamble on so go sign up for
a new account at mybookie use that promo
code bootleg and double your deposit
let's get back to the interview you feel
like now that you're you have like a
high profile as an artist
is it take a special type of Dude to
like get down with Armani Caesar because
he has to kind of understand that you're
a boss [ __ ] that you got this thriving
rap career that you're a public figure
like there's so many things that like
like I think when I think of like uh
you know
powerful women intimidate men it just is
what it is yeah I think
um yeah it's difficult for a man to date
a woman because I think
um at least in my case
it's already like God's Gonna judge you
off of how you look anyway and expect
you to be a certain way not realizing
like you know I actually am an Avid
Reader I like deep conversations I like
you know what I'm saying they may look
at me and Judge Me based off of you know
Instagram or whatever the case may be
like a lot of guys don't really get to
know me from me yeah so they think like
oh man I gotta have like my bag up I
gotta get her to say I gotta get her
that and it's like well or we could just
have a nice conversation
that yeah can we can we can we carry in
our conversation where I'm not born I
want to kill myself yeah I mean that's
why but I write songs about that all the
time like that's where the Liz loves
Luger song came from like I just wanted
your loyalty I want all of that stuff
too because obviously like if I'm gonna
do it for myself I want whoever is
around me to be able to level me like I
love on me but I think you know it's
better stuff like bigger stuff that
matters I think nowadays you know
relationships are so transactional they
are like and social media only
perpetuates that they don't not so now
you don't really know how to deal with
people on just a regular human basis
without it being a transition yeah yeah
what's the uh what's the ulterior motive
what can I get out of this yeah yeah a
lot of men are paying you know to get
with the girls of their dreams and a lot
of women are getting paid for their pain
what is uh you say your average reader
what do you like to read what kind of
books are you reading
um books that's just gonna make me boss
up like
um The Game of Life and how to play it
that's a real good one The Alchemist
um Gucci Mane Guides of greatness was
good I just read that I just read a
perfect day to boss up by Rick Ross
um self-help books self-help books yeah
for sure
I mean and have you heard there's a book
called The subtle art to not giving a
[ __ ] have you heard of that book I heard
of it but I didn't read it it's a pretty
good book okay I think I already know
how to not give a [ __ ] I mean that's
fair like I haven't been giving the [ __ ]
since I was like 12. oh [ __ ] so like you
know it was still a good book though
that's fine I'm gonna look it I'm gonna
read it yeah what about do you what are
you binge watching when you're watching
TV any shows you just [ __ ] love that
you just can't get enough of I'm a
[ __ ] geek like low-key when it comes
to [ __ ] like that like what are you
watching
where you geek out over
I watch Like CinemaSins
um prim's Hood media it's like this they
do like um
reviews on like hood movies
[Laughter]
I haven't heard of this yeah like it's I
like [ __ ] like that I like a lot of
things that like are documentaries or
like things I'm gonna learn from things
that I didn't know especially like if
it's my favorite movie things that I
didn't even notice or like any kind of
like weird quirky facts that you may
never know like I like [ __ ] like that
what's your favorite movie
I got so many favorite movies give me
three of them
I like
um
Friday After Next that's a great one
uh Harlem Nights great one
and
Mean Girls hey Migos
it is it's fire hey Friday After Next
though that's that's uh
I mean I'm OG Friday I like all the
fries I love all three yeah all the
Fridays for sure I think it's Friday
Friday after next then next Friday see I
like Friday After Next because it can be
a Christmas movie it is a Christmas
movie and you know just a regular you
know Katt Williams coming out parties oh
my gosh fire Money Mike
yeah yeah shout out to Money Mike well
look I appreciate you pulling up the
list two is out yes go get that go run
it up more videos on the way yes more
video we got some some uh surprises also
uh uh new music top of the Year yes for
sure you're not gonna make everybody I
mean listen if you're recording albums
in three days I mean but this one I'm
taking my time with I think I'm you know
I'm more so intentional about it like
because I'm I'm I already shown people I
know how to rap right now it's about
making songs and good songs versus you
know just giving people virus I'm Gonna
Give You bars in between anyway you're a
superstar thank you you gotta yeah so
you've proven the rapping part thank you
now you just got to put them hits out
okay because I'm trying to get on some
of these movie soundtracks I need a
movie contract I'm trying to get in you
know all of it all of that stuff there
it is Armani Caesar appreciate you
coming through thank you for having me
boom